Claire, I mean, I feel like you literally
had everybody drink whatever it was
that you were serving up when you walked out
as the queen in "The Crown."
I mean, how does that feel to just lasso in at Word One?
(audience applauding)
How did you approach that?
I'm just curious, 'cause boy, you beyond pulled it off.
You got everyone on your side.
Everyone fell in love with you.
Boom.
Ooh.
I didn't really think about it a lot.
I had a four-month-old baby,
so I was basically trying to make the day
go as fast as humanly possible so I could get home.
Maybe that's the key.
(laughs)
Act fast, go home,
and then, yeah, I don't know
I don't know.
So, you're saying you phoned it in.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
In a nutshell. No, I didn't.
I really put a lot of thought into it, Paul.
I know you did.
Well, I mean, this show really, really works.
It's, your chemistry's so good.
The subject matter's so enticing.
Why do you think people just love scandal so much?
Why do we love it?
We're all trying to be such good people, but God,
we like the naughty stuff.
We love the naughty stuff.
I think that's why.
I think, and that's a really British thing, I think,
as well, that everyone pretends
to be behaving themselves all the time, and secretly,
they're going home and getting up to all sorts.
So, I think that's,
everybody wants to know what everyone else's up to.
It's why people like TV shows because it gives you
kind of a glimpse into other people's lives,
and fortunately,
these two characters did all the things
you sort of dreamed doing yourself.
Had you watched "A Very English Scandal"
before considering "A Very British Scandal?"
I had just, I had seen it,
just 'cause I'd seen it,
and I thought it was great.
I think the tone of this is really different
because the subject matter's-
It is.
A little bit darker.
Very.
But I thought it was beautifully done,
but yeah, we had the luck of having a great, a great writer,
Sarah Phelps, who wrote it,
and an amazing director called Anne Sewitsky,
who is, well, she's Norwegian,
and I think it was really helpful
having somebody who wasn't encumbered
and soaked in sort of British class system
to come in and-
And a woman.
I noticed the second her credit went by.
I was like, okay, a woman directed this.
Interesting.
It's so very compelling, beautifully shot.
In fact, we have a clip.
I'd love to show you guys.
Take a look.
I love it.
I'm gonna sleep at the club.
And tomorrow morning, we go back to Inveraray first train.
I won't be.
You'll do what I tell you to do
and when I tell you to do it.
You must be confusing me with one of your other wives.
(bright music)